and II always good to talk with you how
are you bud what's not broth yeah we
gotta tell the story of how we almost
became teammate I know I would say I was
saying you almost went to the Ivy League
yeah so I drank my first beer on an
official visit at Princeton it was a
Milwaukee's best light by the way and if
I'd have been a little more amenable and
taking out a bunch of giant student
loans then I probably would have been
the guy hosting you on your recruiting
visit when you came up that's amazing I
did my first beer bong on my official
visit I got there in my host who's the
guy you played with goes I signed us up
for a bartending class I'm like okay
sounds great
yeah the visit people have people have
the wrong idea I think sometimes of Ivy
League I had a real good time on my
visit that helped that helps sell me for
sure what was it like by the way I mean
I know you don't have really have
anything compare it to but what was it
like being a walk-on at Florida did you
think you had a chance to play did you
feel like you were part of it or kind of
like a second-class citizen I never
really asked you about that part of it
so I I thought I had a chance to play
until the first practice and then I
realized I was not good enough as one of
those things where you're in high school
and you play against guys that are going
dy like I played against guys that were
headed to Notre Dame and headed to Miami
and all that and I said okay I did okay
against these guys I should be fine
right I guess but then you realize
everybody's like that except a little
bit better at a place the team I walked
onto won the national title so you're
talking about bunch of first-rounder
type guys and I was not good enough not
even close
and yeah but the I tell you what Steve
Spurrier staff they treat the walk-on
and the scholarship players exactly the
same
there was no second-class citizens like
if you can play you can play so if I'd
have been any good I'd have been playing
that's awesome
I mentioned that I'm going to the Penn
State game Saturday and I know the big
game tonight is Ohio State Indiana I was
curious about this one Andy because I
follow the Big Ten because I live in
pencil
Vania you know Penn State beat Ohio
State last year and won the conference
or whatever and Ohio State had what
three D B's go in the first round I mean
they lost a bunch of people Penn State
lost nobody what why do you think it's
the case that Ohio State everybody
thinks it's a foregone conclusion that
they're in the college football playoff
that they're better when we all know how
Penn State finished and they have
everybody back it seems like well hyoh
State returns a whole lot too it's a lot
of it's because you just go law of
probability now Penn State probably
wasn't as consistent as Ohio State was
last year
it's just Penn State got them in that
game and the thinking is Penn State has
to go to Columbus this year it's a
disturbing a stretch where they play
Michigan Ohio State Michigan State right
in a row so I think that that probably
factors into it but you're right about
Penn State being basically as good as
they were last year or better I'm
curious how they handle the different
dynamic that they'll see this year
because last year they were a team on
your schedule this year every team that
plays Penn State is gonna be like oh my
gosh we got to be Penn State they're the
defending Big Ten champs so it's a
little different intensity level in each
game that they're gonna deal with but I
think James Franklin is a very good
coach I said this for years
anybody who can win nine games two years
in a row at Vanderbilt knows what
they're doing I got a feeling that
they're gonna be just fine but the
prodding the thing is Urban Meyer's
track record is pretty unassailable so I
think it probably comes down to those
two teams in the Big Ten East and
probably therefore in the big ten but I
don't I don't think you can go wrong
picking either one at this point Tom
with Andy staples he's the college
football writer for Sports Illustrated
speaking of the Big Ten East there's two
two games that jump out to me on
Saturday Michigan Florida and Alabama
against Florida State I guess let's
start with Florida Michigan Annie I got
a couple quick ones on that one what is
going on with your alma mater ten guys
suspended
the leading researcher the leading
runner I mean what is going on and
potentially more you know the police are
investigating right now that the
University Police are investigating it
that I got a debit card scam and the
details of it are pretty murky I you
hear a bunch of different stories a
bunch of different versions of it I'll
be curious when the police finished
investigating to hear what actually
happened but yeah a lot of guys involved
it seems like and you know there's word
that there may be more suspensions
coming down and the thing is that this
may not be just this game because the
the people who've been suspended have
been held out of practice so it's you
know kind of an indefinite deal and it's
gonna get tricky going forward if they
don't have a Antonio Callaway if they
don't have Jordan scarlet they were
already gonna have some issues because
they never really had a quarterback
distance himself in the competition they
named Philippe Frances started yesterday
my guess is he was the one they plan to
send out first anyway but I think they
named him yesterday because they wanted
to be like hey look over there don't
talk about the suspensions talk about
this right what about Annie Michigan I
guess my question with them is you know
they had what eleven guys drafted last
year they had twenty some guys at least
get into an NFL camp I mean they've been
loaded the last couple years but it
doesn't really feel like John Harbaugh
and the Wolverines have won a big game I
mean at what point am I gonna see you
know a guy that's the highest-paid coach
and everybody talks about how great he
is I you know I I guess I just haven't
seen it yet and at Michigan at least he
took them when they were five and seven
and won ten games that serious not very
easy to do they were one inch away from
beating Ohio State last year and winning
the big penny
so I heart about it okay
interesting thing this year with all the
lost starters because you think with
Ohio State and Penn State being this
good that this will be kind of a
rebuilding year for Michigan and III do
think either Ohio State or Penn State's
going to win the big ten but I don't
think Michigan is going to drop off as
much as people think is remember
Jim Harbaugh was doing all this with
Brady hopes recruits he's now playing
primarily with his recruits these are
the guys you know when he had it he
wrote down his vision for the program
you know this is what I want my
defensive end to look like I want to
look like where Shawn Gary that's what
we got so I think they're not going to
drop off quite as much as people think
because the talent level there was
already pretty high and these a lot of
these guys did play a lot of snaps last
year it's pretty awesome Andy that we've
got Florida State Alabama Saturday night
number one against number three I guess
the question there is how much did this
game really matter in your mind there's
a perception out there that it really
doesn't because even if you lose either
one of these teams still has a great
chance of making the college football
playoff it takes away some margin for
error though because even though Penn
State came very close to making the
playoffs as a two loss team last year we
still haven't seen it yet I'm assuming
it will happen at some point but if you
lose this game
it basically means you need to go
undefeated the rest of the way so if
you're Florida State and you lose this
game that means you got to beat Miami NC
State Louisville Clemson Florida and
then beat somebody else good in the N
ACC championship game that's not easy
you know Alabama it would mean you got
to beat LSU you got to beat Auburn you
got to be you know whoever you might see
in the SEC championship game not easy so
yeah you can say oh it doesn't hurt you
if you lose well yeah it does because
you got to go undefeated the runs away
probably and that's not a position that
either one of these teams wants to be in
but the thing is it is such a big ship
for the winner I mean Ohio State got in
a playoff last year because they went to
Norman and boat race to Oklahoma that
was that was the reason they got in the
playoffs so my guess is if there's any
sort of doubt at the end of the season
about the winner of this game and
whether they should make the playoffs
winning this game would give them the
best you know the committee would then
give them the benefit of the doubt so I
know what your answer is going to be to
this Andy but
we have a poll question today and we're
hoping that you can at least make your
pitch and try to be objective as much as
possible because I heard you guys
talking about it last segment and I
think it's a really interesting topic
and I we get in this discussion a lot
about whether the pro game is better or
the college game is better or why there
are certain people who just prefer
watching college football the pro
football there's a couple reasons one I
will say is Geographic if you grew up in
the south like I did you don't feel as
big of an attachment to proteins because
there's not really a generational
attachment you know the Buccaneers came
to Tampa two years before I was born
right so actually no I'm sorry the Bucs
started playing a year after I was born
the Falcons were relatively new the
Dolphins were fairly new so like grandpa
didn't say we've been dolphins fans all
our lives or anything like that but you
don't have that attachment but grandpa
did say we've been Alabama fans all our
lives where we've been South Carolina
fans all our lives and so it's a much
deeper connection to college football
itself just because there were there
weren't proteins for years and years and
years the other part of it is I think a
lot of people like the diversity of
playing college football you have option
teams you have air raid teams you have
pro style teams there's so many
different ways to skin a cat in college
football and in pro football
everything looks almost the same now if
you really understand the intricacies
you can see what's going on but to the
average person it kind of looks the same
and there's a lot of reasons for that
one the athletes are so good like you
couldn't run the option in the NFL the
all the decent the decent players move
too fast sideline to sideline and
they're so good at being coached that oh
I'm supposed to hit the diag man I will
hit the dive man every time college guys
don't always do that and then also the
hash marks are closer in the NFL which
we could get into a real walky
discussion about that but it does limit
your offensive diversity
yeah I'm with you and I and there's I
you just brought up another question for
me that I'm gonna ask when we come back
because I think it's important in the
discussion but and II really appreciate
your time thank you so much for coming
on as always all right thank you all
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience